>> From the Library of Congress
in Washington, D.C.
>> First it is my sincere pleasure
to introduce our main [inaudible] --
>> Okay.
>> -- Rich.
I think she is finally getting
her sound up and running.
Thanks, Cindy.
Cindy is Director of the Library of Congress
Teaching with Primary Sources Program
at Eastern Illinois University
in Charleston, Illinois.
She's also a faculty member in the
Department of Secondary Education there
where she teaches a course
on literacy, differentiation,
and assessment for pre-service
teachers seeking certification
in any secondary level content area.
I'm Cheryl Lederle, and I'm an Educational
Resource Specialist at the Library of Congress
and I'll be supporting Cindy on this session.
One of my jobs in that support
role is to collect questions
and I will be giving those back to Cindy in
the last 10 minutes of our time together.
So it looks like many of
you have found the Chat Box.
Please use that box again to enter
your questions and I'll collect them.
Now I'm going to turn this over to Cindy Rich.
>> So I want to thank you
very much for taking time
to join this session this evening, actually.
We're very excited to be here this afternoon for
the first Library of Congress Online Conference
for Teachers, and we are going to jump right in.
During this session we're going to
talk a little bit about opportunities
to increase content knowledge and free
students' minds and promote inquiry.
Strong literacy skills and content knowledge
free the mind for independence and inquiry
and everytime I see this slide I think
of the En Vogue song, "Free Your Mind
and the Rest Will Follow," because it
really -- it just happens naturally.
Once we empower our students to go after
information, the rest will just come.
We'll look at ways that we can make this happen,
and I hope you'll continue your discussions
and sharing ideas in the chat area.
You won't offend us at all.
Teachers are great at multitasking, but I
would like to ask you, if you don't mind,
just share in that chat box
what maybe state you're from
and then also what content area you teach just
so we can have an idea of
who's in the room with us.
Math, civics, library.
This is awesome.
We have a nice mix of both
grade levels and content areas.
And I think that's the beauty of
literacy, that we are all going
through the same steps trying
to help students learn.
And we're going to talk about that today.
All right.
We've even got pre-K through 12
represented with the library.
Wonderful.
This is a great mix.
This is so exciting and I'm
so pumped to see this.
Okay. Well, hopefully, we'll hit something for
everyone, and while we're doing this, please,
please, please be more than willing to share
with your colleagues online here what you're
doing and how any of these things apply
to your classroom or anything
you want to contribute.
The first thing we're going to talk about
in this session is that we're going to talk
about the value of engaging learners and
activating prior knowledge to establish
that foundation within a content area.
Schools are a little bit unique because we
expect our students to leave one classroom
and then enter another classroom while they
completely shift their focus, all right?
And for those of you in the middle school
and the high school we won't even talk
about the adolescent brain
in asking them to do this.
But we know that the real
world doesn't work that way.
Whenever we work with people and talk
with people we're constantly crossing content
areas and, you know, what we're talking
about primarily in one meeting
may come up during other meetings,
but it's sort of like the waves on
a beach where the topics come in
and go out and just kind of crash together.
And so we're asking our students to
switch just because a bell rings.
And so it's important that we get them all
on the same page when we start a class.
We want everyone to be on that same
page but we know and we recognize
that students have different skill levels and
interests when they come into our classrooms.
And so we want to be able to
pull that out of those students
so everyone can learn from what we're doing.
The second part of this session
is going to be looking
at how we can present key content information
while also supporting literacy skills
and using primary sources as teaching tools.
Again, those multitasks that we're so good at.
The key to this is making the
primary source work for you.
We all know primary sources are
really cool, but you want to be sure
that you're getting something from that primary
source when you use it in a learning activity.
And it needs to earn its
place in your classroom.
It's not just decoration.
It has to be, the primary source has to
be a tool that you're using to teach.
Of course this involves really thoughtful
planning before you even select a
primary source.
And so those primary sources
need to be relevant,
appropriate, and best of all, engaging.
Luckily, the Library of Congress
has millions of these,
so we won't have a problem
finding ones that we can use.
As teachers within our content areas,
you already know which strategies are effective
during different points of the learning cycle.
And so we're going to choose strategies that
give opportunities for repeated exposure
to vocabulary and concepts, expose
students to the nuances, academic language,
and discourse of your content area or
whatever topic you're talking about,
and encourage students to connect and
transfer information within our content area,
and in a perfect world outside of our content
area in what they're learning down the hall.
And I can't make the slides change, so I don't
know if Kathy or Cheryl can help me with that.
Thank you.
We'll do a little game when it comes time.
All right.
To start out, each of us bring a unique
perspective, background, our strengths,
our weaknesses, and interest
into what we're doing.
And this is what makes teaching
amazing but also makes it challenging.
So if you don't mind, in the
chat area, would you let us know,
is this your first year teaching, 20th
year teaching, or somewhere in-between?
I'm very curious as to what
level of -- all right.
Student teaching, pre-service,
22 years, 23 years.
Great. I lost count.
I get that.
All right.
Well, each of us are bringing our own
level of expertise in anything we do.
But no matter how long you've
been doing it, you speak teaching.
We know that, you know, just by looking at
this there are teachers who speak science,
teachers who speak social
studies, special education,
and all these different content areas.
But now my question for you
is, what else do you speak?
And so this may be a hobby, it may
be a content area, it may be a skill,
it may be a medical condition, anything
that you know well enough that you speak.
Margaret speaks tech.
Chris speaks politics.
Mack speaks swimming.
Arnie speaks [inaudible] outdoors, tennis.
All right, we're seeing hobbies, we're
seeing work, we're seeing pleasure.
And this is awesome because it may come
from a desire to something you want
to do or it may come from necessity.
But you've learned the art
of discourse in that topic.
Genealogy, athletics, very cool.
What a great group.
Man, I wish we were all together.
This would be fun.
All right.
So we know, though, for students who are
new to a concept or struggle with materials,
something as small as vocabulary
can be a -- we are together, Cheryl.
You're right.
All right.
We could be -- something as simple
as vocabulary can be a hurdle.
And so we want to take that
hurdle away for our students.
Have you ever been in a situation where everyone
in a conversation knows someone and is talking
about them, but you have
no idea who that person is?
That little piece of information
comes in really handy.
We want our students to be in a position
where they know what we're talking about.
If they don't know what you're
talking about they can't take it
to the next level and get the information.
So we're going to talk about these
terms on the screen in a few minutes.
Have you ever heard any -- I mean
this is a rhetorical question.
Have you heard any or all
of these terms defined?
In the chat I'm going to ask you to share either
a formal definition for any of these words
that you've heard or just a -- in casual
conversation how you heard these described.
There are no wrong answers here.
I'm not asking you to define them.
I'm asking what you have heard
in relation to these terms.
So you can't get it wrong.
Nice, Matthew.
All right.
Literacy and fluency.
Jenna says informational texts are
boring, which we all know they're not.
Sometimes we're convincing our students that.
All right.
Well, not to rush you, but for the sake of
this presentation, these are the meanings
that I've assigned to these words.
It doesn't mean that other
descriptions or definitions are wrong.
These are just within the context of
this session what we're going to use.
So for informational text, remove this from
the fiction/nonfiction or genre conversation.
For this presentation, we're simply
going to refer to informational text
as anything you get information from.
All right?
Common Core state standard documentation
says that informational texts are books
about diverse topics, technical texts,
and digital sources on a range of topics.
But we are talking big.
I want you to just think no limits as
to what an informational text can be.
Literacy. Once upon a time it was simply
defined as the ability to read and write.
But now the term literacy's heard all
over academic walls and means knowledge
that relates to a specific subject.
Literacy has become complete embedded in our
normal vocabulary to describe the ability
to strategically understand and
communicate an act within a context.
And last week, I know I've heard the phrases
"financially literate, football literate,
and cancer literate," because
these are different contexts
where people learn a language, learn
how to both give and take information,
and how to perform or act within that context.
So it's being aware.
And then fluency, if we think about being fluent
in a foreign language or a second language,
it's basically the ability to not just
be able to say the words and speak it,
but to go beyond just recognition
to comprehend and construct meaning.
We want them to speak science and be fluent
in science, or Shakespeare, or politics,
or the Harlem Renaissance, or whatever it is
that we're talking about in our classroom.
Once they're able to fluently speak the
content then they can really dig into the meat
of what we're doing in our class.
By mastering contextual awareness we can focus
on the deeper understanding and new knowledge.
All right.
From the Library of Congress
Teachers Page and experiences,
I know primary sources engage students.
Primary sources help students relate
in a personal way to events of the past
and promote deeper understanding of
history as a series of human events.
Because primary sources are snippets
of history, they encourage students
to seek additional evidence through
research and first person accounts
of events help make them more real,
fostering active reading and response.
A thoughtfully selected primary source
can be provocative and set a tone
for a class activity or a learning environment.
You chose something like this image
that we're looking at right now.
It's a pretty casual tone.
But it's interesting to us.
What part of this image grabbed your attention?
We've got some fishermen and fisherwomen, right?
Love this.
Especially the ME, the gas sign, the prices.
Jenna noticed the font size
because it was large.
Megan noticed the cactus.
Very good.
You guys are noticing it all.
The U Drive It Cars.
They were texting a long time ago apparently.
Alrighty. Well, as we look at
things that get your attention,
we're using our prior knowledge and experiences.
We put this new information into a schema
or context that's meaningful for us.
So we have our first impression,
but now let's closely read the image
for a specific purpose, all right?
Do you think this photo was
taken in your home town?
Maybe or maybe not.
What context clues do you use to
determine a location for this photo?
All right.
We're looking at plants, the
language, the spelling, the cactus.
All right.
Near a body of water.
Very good.
Also you guys are doing great.
Well, we know this photo --
Oops, sorry.
Put the arrow on the computer.
All right.
This photo is actually from
Santa Fe, New Mexico.
It was taken in 1938 by Dorothea Lange, and
many of you probably know Dorothea Lange's work.
She did the Migrant Mother and a lot
of the iconic photos that we see today.
Anyway. The Post-its in this picture
represent the thoughts of one of my colleagues.
We use what we know, our
background, to read this photo.
And then we use the vocabulary
based on what we know to discuss it.
So, while my science friends can
talk about the plant species,
I can talk about the fishing worms.
All right.
We each have strengths, and
interests that we bring to what we do.
But we're putting it into a schema
or context that's meaningful to us.
You know, the question, Maria, what
did they mean by U Drive It Cars?
That's a really good question because
in 1938 I don't know what was happening
with rental cars and things like that.
So that's a great question, all right?
So we put this into a sense of place but it
may be something we're interested in the time
that the photo was taken or even just
we're interested in the price of gas
and how much it's changed and why
we can't go back to those prices.
But this explains how the image draws you
in and where you want to go from there.
So within this activity we just did
real quickly, and I won't define all
of these every time because we will run out of
time, but we're looking at contextual awareness.
This is the frame of reference.
We're using explicit and
implicit clues to build knowledge,
recognizing the evidence that's there.
But that we each use evidence differently
or find different types of evidence.
We're triggering our prior knowledge.
We're using context clues,
both words and images.
We're thinking about the
author purpose if we look
at that sign and the breakdown of gas prices.
And then the real life application,
bringing it into our lives.
What the heck does this have to do with me?
Well, I know I complain about gas prices.
The next primary source I'm showing you.
We're going to look at mastering contextual
vocabulary and nuances because once we do
that we can move into deeper understanding
and new information, all right?
So as teachers we know introducing a word
in isolation is not an effective
way to teach vocabulary.
Our students benefit if we're able to reinforce
new terms through either morphemic awareness,
breaking it down into those word
parts, my English teacher friends,
and that -- and using context clues.
In the end we want them to be able
to decode new words on their own.
That's a life skill.
It's something we need to
empower them into doing.
If they aren't caught up in the mechanics of
reading, they gain independence and confidence,
and then can really focus on the
content and what else they want to know.
We need to know where students stand regarding
vocabulary and concepts in a specific content.
So instead of finding, you know, kind of content
area specific resources for this presentation,
I picked some that were just kind
of interesting to me in that.
So this is a piece of sheet music,
"Take Me Out to the Ballgame."
All right.
So within a new context it's demanding to
receive information while still trying to decode
or understand what the words mean.
Look at the lyrics of the song.
Which words catch your eye as we
discuss vocabulary and nuances?
Crackerjacks.
We know that one.
Everybody must be hungry.
Root. Excellent.
They know the word "root."
They know "home team."
What's another phrase maybe?
Very good.
You guys are on top of it.
All right.
So we see "Root, root, root for the home team."
Students will know what the word "root" means.
But the fact that it's used differently here,
and it's used three times, has specific meaning.
Home team, they should understand
that when we explain it.
And then the same for "Three
strikes you're out."
That's a different context
in different settings,
and without understanding
what it means in this context,
they wouldn't get the gist of what the song is.
This time we're looking at vocabulary.
Words we know, old words that we already
know, but applying them to a new meaning.
Context clues and contextual language.
And so, great.
We're seeing in the chat how
people are using the word "root,"
and how it can be perceived differently.
And these are little obstacles that can
slow our students down in the classroom
that we may not think to mention.
All right.
I've got another good one for you.
Do you know enough to know what to ask?
An initial look at a primary source is
naturally going to inspire questions.
But to formulate those questions
students use their literacy skills
to receive information while
[inaudible] -- start over again.
Students use literacy skills to receive
information while they're connecting again
with that prior knowledge and schema.
So the question is, do you know enough
about the content to even know what to ask?
This is where fluency comes in.
We want our classrooms to be a
space where students are encouraged
to ask questions and are praised for doing so.
We should nurture this.
This is why we as teachers love to
answer a question with a question, right?
A thoughtful question requires a student
to determine what it is they want
to know and why they want to know it.
Successfully establishing a purpose
for a question requires comprehending
and critiquing a source.
So they have to know what they don't know.
And that's moving to the
next level of understanding.
If I add another photo, do
your questions change?
Does your frame of reference shift?
As we acquire new information it may answer
some questions we had from the first picture.
But now we may have even more
questions about what we're looking at.
This is where we draw upon our expertise.
And when we choose classroom strategies
we try to find things that are going
to guide students through this process.
For example, if we use a primary source
analysis sheet that's going to lead them
from low-level thinking skills or
just observation to more synthesis
in using the information and
drawing their own conclusions.
Or we may even use something like
a Venn diagram to do a compare
and contrast with a photo like this.
The top photo, as you can see, were the Chicago
Cubs, National League Pennant Winners in 1929.
The bottom photo was the first
Colored World Series opening game,
October 11, 1924, in Kansas City, Missouri.
So, as you can see, I'm partial
to the Midwest here.
All right.
Again, we're using those literacy skills.
Looking at context and setting relationships.
The implicit and explicit details.
Things like, why is there a huge crowd in
the bottom picture, but not in the top?
So we want to move through things like that,
that these skills are really important.
This is why we thoughtfully
select our primary sources.
All right.
Okay, we got started a little bit late so I'm
going to kind of rush through this a little bit.
By understanding text structure we can focus
on deeper understanding and new knowledge.
So we've talked about vocabulary and
we've talked about contextual awareness.
But what about text structure?
The following slides are
a part of my own research.
We had an ice storm here in
Illinois a few years ago.
And I thought, well, I'm going to look
and see what types of resources I can find
that I can use to talk about weather
from maybe a hundred years ago.
And so went to Chronicling America.
And Chronicling America is amazing.
There's a session going on right now
and hopefully some of you will be able
to watch the recording of that because
it's just an unbelievable collection.
But as I was pursuing through all the front
pages and articles I found references to a storm
in the early days of 1912, and it was
a horrific cold wave that went through.
So once I found my date,
moved on with my search.
But before we even start looking at content,
let's talk about the importance
of text structure, all right.
We know how a newspaper is structured.
We know what it looks like.
So remember our students today
may not have that knowledge.
But we know that what are some
of the attributes of a newspaper
that you see in the text structure?
All right.
Larger type in the headlines.
Just the use of headlines at all.
Great, Amy and Annette.
Right. And Janelle talking about the bylines.
The date's usually pretty easy to find.
Good. So all these little attributes.
And you know we want to talk about these things
when we work with students with their textbooks
about unit headings and font
size and things like that,
but here in the newspaper we can see it as well.
But we also know that the text structure
supports how we acquire information.
And so, you know, we may look
specifically for just the main headlines.
But we also want to look at smaller
text, different types of fonts,
and all that to see how much
information is shared.
So on the topic of text structure we're
looking at, how would structured --
how one thing relates to another, how a story
develops through the use of the text structure,
the relationships between text,
implicit/explicit details, and author intent.
Why did a newspaper choose
that to be their headline?
If we have contextual fluency
and understand text structure,
we can then move into something called
author intent and diverse perspectives.
All right.
So now, being confident in my ability
to maneuver around Chronicling America,
understanding text structure,
recognizing familiar vocabulary,
I stop thinking about the
mechanics of my search.
I was able to concentrate on the content
that I wanted to know what was happening
with these storms in different parts
of the country on January 6th of 1912.
This is where the real fun started.
But while getting lost in these pages of
old newspapers, and I mean hundreds of pages
of old newspapers, I made
two important discoveries.
Take a look at these pages
and see what catches your eye.
What do they have in common?
What differs?
What else do you want to know?
Weather.
Cold.
Right? And, of course, at the very
top of each one, right, geography.
There you go.
At the very top we see the
name of the newspaper,
where it is, where this was happening.
We also see that, you know,
the date is featured there.
It's a little blurry on these
but it's also available.
But we see what different newspapers chose
to put its headlines on their front page,
and how important a front page is.
So we see, again, text structure,
relationships, and recurring words.
All three of these newspapers
talked about the cold.
referred to suffering
and relief and distress that was happening.
And so that is important.
It was important to see how this
was reported from different places.
New York and Washington were experiencing this.
But really important, the Hawaiian Star .
That one blew my mind, first
of all because 1912.
Was Hawaii even a state at that point?
Nope. Exactly.
So they were curious.
They were concerned of what
was happening in the mainland.
And I found that really interesting.
And I am powering through these.
I apologize.
I'm going so fast.
All right?
This is a headline and the first few
sentences of one of the articles.
You can see the entire article on the right.
But for now we're just going
to focus on this part.
The one on the right is from
Chronicling America.
You can do clippings of articles
and use them with students.
It's an amazing tool.
But in these brief paragraphs do you see the
vocabulary that keeps recurring or themes?
All right.
We see widespread weather.
If we look at the headlines, do the words that
we see underneath support those headlines?
Temperature, temperature, cold.
All right.
Well we previously talked about -- remember we
saw the same words used in different context
within "Take Me Out to the Ballgame"?
In examples like this, we're using the
same words within the same context.
But why are they used so many
times within the same context?
All right.
We see the word "suffering" several times.
"Charity' and "aid."
The reason this is mentioned so many times
is because this is a key plate in the text,
and so we want students to
understand that, that whatever,
you know, details are provided repeatedly.
That usually means it's an important point and
so we want them to focus on things like that.
And Michelle said all of these are
hot-linked within this presentation
and will be available at the end, too.
All right.
So students can see how to
construct arguments, all right?
The headline is, "There's Much
Suffering Already in the City."
And they say, the suffering's
already widespread.
The next paragraph, widespread suffering.
We can also focus and purposely
receive information.
Asking our students to focus on key points and
repeated words gives them a purpose for reading.
And as they're starting to look at something
they may create their own hypothesis
and either confirm or contradict
the hypothesis that they had.
So in 1912 snow was going to
be accompanied by zero weather.
Temperatures were scheduled to drop.
Much suffering already.
However, the children in Washington see
a bright side in the skating prospect,
so at least the children were
looking on the bright side.
All right.
So we looked at what was information
was reported on the same day
and how it may have been fluctuating
from two different locations.
We think about things like that.
When I think about events like 911
and how it was presented differently
in different countries, or how people react
to events differently in different places,
letting students look at
information like that and compare
and contrast those diverse perspectives, and
then also come up with their own conclusion
as to why people in different
communities reacted in different ways.
So we looked at that.
Now we're going to look at how information
is reported differently within two cities.
This Washington Times front page
at the top left there, the big one,
says "Charity workers are busy with the poor."
And so that leads us to think
this is a really important story.
This is a major topic.
But then the Chicago based
Day Book made little mention
of the cold ravaging the
city on their front page.
And you have to go all the way to
page seven to find information.
But on page seven we have the whole story.
All right.
Now I'm embarrassed to admit this,
but it had never crossed my mind
that a hundred years ago people were
concerned with what to do with the homeless
in the city during harsh winters.
That had just never occurred to me.
And so as I'm looking at this,
all of a sudden it's like wow,
I didn't even know what I
didn't know about this topic.
It goes on about what the fire
departments and the police
and different charities were
doing for people at this time.
And so my fluency level with regards to
that topic in today's time I'm aware of it.
But a hundred years ago I was not.
So I started drawing on what I know now
to understand what they were
talking about a hundred years ago.
This article details the plight of homeless men
and endangered women and
children in Chicago in 1912.
So beyond just looking at how things
are reported in different places
or how things are reported at different,
you know, cities and perspectives,
but here we're looking at
information a century apart.
And considering the perspectives in
that way, connecting it with our life.
And so one of the ways that we use this article
with some cities was through annotation.
In using annotation, students
can, they can identify main ideas.
And the awesome thing about Library
of Congress primary sources is
that you can print those items out
or pull them up on your SMART Board
and let students actively engage
with them, get hands-on involvement
with it, but identifying main ideas.
Bright arrows to, you know, connect ideas.
This happened first.
This happened second.
It can go as -- and Jenna talks about
have you been able to teach annotation?
That's a great question, Jenna.
And how people are using
this in their classroom.
It may be something very basic like just
highlighting main ideas and taking them
through the stages of developing
annotation skills
because it isn't easy and it's not natural.
It's something that we have to
think about while we're doing.
But through the different colors
and I'm a very visual learner.
I like different colored highlighters
and Post-its and things like that.
I like the arrows.
I like being able to interact with the text.
Letting students circle words
that they don't recognize
or anything that's new and giving them a chance.
So, you know, hopefully the rest of you are
using things like this in your classroom
as well either through annotation or
just multiple texts at the same time,
presenting information in those multiple texts.
So I am like so proud of
myself right now because we --
yes, they can be downloaded
and most of them are available.
And whenever you go into Chronicling
America, Rebecca, you can clip them
and they come as a PDF or a jpeg.
Chronicling America has some very cool stuff.
So, to wrap this up, this is, you know,
one of -- what I preach all the time.
To be literate in a specific context
is the difference between existing
and thriving within that context.
And it's not good enough for our
students just to exist in our classrooms.
We want our students to thrive.
And so on that note the next slide is going
to just be a list of -- oh, there we go.
Cheryl's on top of things.
And these are the resources
from this presentation
and that's all I've got, so thank you very much.
>> Thanks so much, Cindy.
This was a whirlwind, but I think
you really hit some highlights,
and the chat conversation suggests
some wonderful lively conversation.
So the first question that I have for you is,
with so many different disciplines represented
in today's webinar meeting, any starting
places or tips to people to integrate literacy
into disciplines or classes where that might
not be a traditional part of the teaching
but we all see -- read the standards
and read the movements towards integrating
literacy across the curriculums.
So, thoughts on how to get
started and especially
if this isn't what is your central focus.
>> That's actually a great question because
so often, whenever we talk about literacy,
people assume we're just
talking about the act of reading.
And it's so much more than that.
And so the first step is to think beyond
the mechanics of reading letters on a piece
of paper, that there's so much
more to it, that it is vocabulary,
that it's understanding what the topic is, that
it's reading, writing, speaking, and listening,
and be able to do it with a
purpose as opposed to just doing it.
And so, really what we're doing, it's --
literacy is so much more than
just getting information.
It's actually -- it's understanding
and using information.
So it is as simple as teaching your students
how to speak within your content area.
It's the vocabulary and the nuances,
how information is organized
within your content area.
Information in science is organized
differently than it is in the history classroom.
And so little things like that are really
developing literacy skills from day one.
Most teachers are doing it.
They're just not calling it that.
>> First I want to thank
everybody for joining us.
We do have a few minutes so go ahead and
put those questions in the chat box if you'd
like while we have Cindy Rich
and the combined experience
and information of all of the participants.
This has been a rich and lively conversation.
For completing this session you have earned
a certificate worth one instructional hour
and you will receive an e-mail
within five business days
with directions on how to access that.
Amy has a great question.
Where would be a great place to start searching
for primary sources within your content?
One of the things that I know frustrates
some teachers is that the Library
of Congress website is not Google.
And so I always tell students
and teachers that I work with,
you have to know what you're looking for before
you start looking on the Library of Congress.
This is not for the lighthearted.
You have to have some knowledge
and understanding
of the content area before you start.
And so, really, it's -- it, you know,
everybody knows that the Library
of Congress site can be daunting because it
is just so huge and it offers so much for us.
But you can go into the Teachers
Page and look for primary source sets
that have already been created
and use those as an inspiration.
Or just, you know, my go-to move is going to
that Home Page and starting on that search box
and just typing something in, and then
seeing what comes up in other subjects
and other related terms and other places
that come up within those answers.
And so, you know, that's a great way to do it.
And, of course, Ask a Librarian which,
you know -- Dana, a foot out there.
But I was going to say that, Dana,
because it always blows my mind
how quickly someone gets back
to me with the Ask a Librarian.
I mean, you guys are so on top of
things at the Library of Congress
and it is a wonderful, wonderful resource.
They're there to help you and, man, they'll
guide you in your search to save you
so much time, and just as,
you know, get your confidence
up that you're heading in the right direction.
>> We have done a webinar on Chronicling America
for National History Day a couple of weeks ago,
and we have another one coming
up in mid-November.
One of the things that Lynn O'Hara says
over and over again when we work with NHD is
that any text in the hands and
mind of a creative student can work
for a National History Day theme.
They make those themes deliberately pretty
broad so that it's easy to make connections.
So Dana's chiming in again.
Dana is the Reference Librarian
for the Library's Education Team.
Remember earlier, Cindy mentioned
that time when people are talking
about somebody that most everybody else knows.
We had a little insider joke about Dana
who's chiming in about Ask a Librarian.
But we do have lots of starting places
for finding primary sources and
Cindy named a bunch of them.
And we also do have Ask a Librarian to help you.
We are now at the end of our time together,
so I want to say thank you so much.
Thank you, Cindy Rich, for sharing
such a carefully crafted
presentation of so many strategies.
Thank you, again, to all of the participants for
sharing from your perspectives and experiences.
If you haven't taken a moment to go to the
Survey Monkey link, it's three short questions.
Your feedback really does help
us shape future programming.
So I am going to stop the recording
and then end the meeting with,
again, a word of thanks to all of you.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.